foreign
joins us up next in Fresno California
Fallon welcome to the show how you doing
I'm great thanks for having me on yeah
what's going on
so I am currently on workers pump I'm a
surgical assistant and I got hurt before
I got hurt I was looking for another job
it is just a I love what I do but the
culture the environment I'm just I
wasn't very happy there
um I have gone on an interview and
actually have an opportunity to take a
position
but I'm selling workers comp so do I
put in my two week notice do I get off I
don't know what to do now
well are there any terms that say you
can't put in your two weeks while you're
on workers comp
yeah um
you know light duty but the light duty
that I have uh just coincides with
working as a surgical assistant but it
doesn't coincide with this new job that
I'm applied for and got the offer for so
what's the start date of the new job
um I didn't tell them
um the new job that I'm on uh disability
and I just said you know uh can I get at
least give them a two week so I have two
weeks to kind of figure this out and I
want to go out respectfully I don't are
you able to burn any Bridges no I get it
are you able to start this new job in
two weeks or are you still disabled
uh no I know and I can
um well this is a non-issue something
that pops my shoulder out well then you
shouldn't be taking workers comp if
you're fine and you should resign and
you should resign well so you should put
your two weeks in
I'm not even sure I understand
really the heart of your question if I
if I've got your details you're are you
worried you're going to lose the workers
comp by taking the new job
no I'm worried uh because I well I had a
doctor's appointment today I tried to
get off workers comp and they said give
it another week
yeah but so I'm I'm trying I've been
trying to get off and they keep telling
me well you know you can't grasp or grip
anything I'm like but I can who's this
who's the doctors uh the the doctor the
workers comp doctor mind you the same
doctor hasn't looked at me in the eye
the past four weeks I've been in there
okay so all right thank you for sharing
that so here this is very simple
Fallon you're in charge
you go in today today's Friday I'd give
my two weeks today
they'll decide on the workers comp it's
not up to you but you don't need workers
comp if the workers comp doctor is not
looking in the eye and whatever nonsense
is going on there none of that's
relevant to what you should do you're
ready to start this new job in two weeks
yes or no
yes yes is there an underlying fear
of taking this new job and putting your
two weeks
honestly I think it's more of a like
internal like I haven't told anybody I'm
looking for a job and I've been using so
is it Guild Pond workers comp I've been
using yeah kind of why I I mean what are
you guilty of tell me tell me something
that you've done wrong
I mean I even asked when I was working I
asked for a day off so
another job like I just feel bad
okay I just feel like it's not I'm not
having the Integrity that I do have but
I I hate the position I'm in right now
did you do something did you do
something ethically or morally wrong
when you asked for the day off did was
it a paid day off paid vacation
uh yeah I did a PTO was it part of your
package
yes yeah did you do anything morally or
ethically or legally wrong
no all right then
the right thing to do is to quit With
Honor today and be kind and say hey
here's the deal I found another job
that's just much better for me and
appreciate this opportunity and I'm
giving you my two weeks notice
you're a good person but you're worried
about something you shouldn't worry
about
okay and found there is more Integrity
in you leaving well than in you staying
at a place where your heart is Left
Right and your body needs to go with it
now and so I know it it hurts it's like
a breakup when you leave a job there's
people that you care about there they've
treated you well for the most part it
sounds like and so the guilt is coming
from the sense of I owe them something
because they gave me a job correct
yeah that's exactly it right so what I'm
telling you is you've done nothing wrong
that's why I walked you through those
questions you just said you've done
nothing wrong so therefore a person who
has done nothing wrong should not be
guilty what's really happening is you're
worried about what they're going to say
about you or think about you but you got
to choose you got to choose your future
and your life and not worry about what
people are going to say about you am I
right
yeah
I know and as a fellow people pleaser it
is easier said than done yeah it is I
want people pleaser too but I'm gonna
tell you something I'm gonna choose a
better life as opposed to worry about
giving everybody the greatest impression
well I'll tell you what it turns into
testing it turns into resentment yeah
when it sits too long yeah resign today
okay yeah that's what I'm doing then uh
that's resign instead of resent yes you
can hear the relief on her oh we just
the weight on her shoulders yeah it was
a lot yeah she's a good person and
absolutely